the Mandalorian episodes seven people
the one consistently good Star Wars
thing to come at Disney guys our rise of
Skywalker review the non-spoiler one is
now up on YouTube please check it out
there's an opening sketch there that
people seem to be really be enjoying
that's the main thing I want you to go
there for I'm not gonna lie I haven't
read any comments your show oh is that
what it says for for calling things dumb
pointing out good but also saying
there's a lot of dumb things it's do as
the date just kept going on I think when
we walked out of the movie because I
just binge doll the films I really just
want her to hone in on like what I what
I did enjoy about it I mean you're with
me the more I kept talking about it the
more the things I really did I've grown
to hate a lot of things and I haven't
seen any spoiler talks those none of
them are out yeah and everyone will hate
a little something different like the
things I like the things I like are
there are things that are beginning to
really overlap the things that I did
like so we're gonna shoot our spoiler
talk later today and it'll be held here
this weekend you Eric over at nerd
chronic is editing these reaction
highlights for us this was only ten
minutes allowed to go up on YouTube our
full interaction stream along where you
can sync up with the time code is
available over our patreon page along
with a bunch of other shows we'll talk
about later but Eric thanks so much for
cutting this together he's done work for
people like August on Eamon snow movie
trivia Schmo down and he has podcasts or
podcasts or he's a great dude lastly I
want to mention before we go into this
mandalorian is a weekly show make sure
to subscribe today and click that
notification bell so you can notify when
our next man dare reaction is that
married oh right and every action is
let's redirect attention away from Rises
Skywalker and the Lord
[Music]
so here is my proposition return to
Navas bring the child is big I will
arrange an exchange and provide loyal
guild members as protection once we get
the other client you kill him and we
both get what we want
[ __ ] yes
[Music]
oh so happy to be here with Star Wars we
can agree on yeah Gina Carano doing the
things Gina Carano does you can live
free of worry
I'm already for every boy and I'm not
meant to play soldier anymore especially
fighting some local warlord he's not a
local warlord
he's Imperial the enemy I mean that's
how it suckers one word you saw what
happened once order I'll keep sending
hussars the kid will never be safe until
the IMP is dead
Oh baby Yoda what are you doing go what
are you doing baby Yoda man no you need
be a better dad
yeah leave your kid in the cockpit you
got any Amy Sedaris
do you think so maybe that's why he was
in the recap it all makes sense now
yeah we thought this was just epic no it
is realized television I don't know if I
could trust the Droid and we do it not
for payment but to protect the child
from Imperial slavery and won't be free
until the old ways have gone forever
just wait till the first order shows up
he said it she said the lot got our
quota we had she in here she has to take
down all the armors
what baby
Yoda do you baby Yoda what are you doing
don't force Joker what story you told
what is it what is I don't know but what
it does what when you work for the
Empire when I was sold to the Empire
threatened him you guys we're all
supposed to get along no this is a
cinematic crossover from many episodes
who to trust provided a security detail
precious little creature I can see why
you didn't know to harm a hair on
wrinkled little head
well I'm glad this matter will be put to
rest once and for all
[Music]
oh this Star Wars animal no already
strike let's go over the plan again we
both entered the common house we show
the client the bait the table and you
kill it
tell me about his reinforcements I got a
bad feeling about this
don't tell me the odds chorus Wow a
headphones on that was really scary
yeah no no no oh good grief
carga oh sorry I didn't know them no
they were so nice though
[Music]
oh love when this show plays into the
horror yeah
oh no grief you're not throw in the
towel references me or to heal and you
know him life for stuff come on come on
come on baby oh hell yeah all rise
[Music]
Oh grief is gonna be like I was gonna
betray you but I don't think I should
yeah I got a confession to make that god
damn it
grief something you should know
yeah that's going to betray the plan was
to kill you and take the kid but after
what happened last night I couldn't go
through called it 10 seconds before it
happened yeah that's how good I listen
trap me
what'd you tell him you captured me get
me close to him give you blood you mean
like the original plan I think this work
will in the crate yeah he's he's evolved
yeah he's grown he's Nick don't love it
too yeah
everyone loves you baby Yoda it is so
cute you Rizzo Q you're gonna sell so
many Funko pops can I offer you a
libation to celebrate the closing of our
shared narrative write his own dialogue
poet feel like he must have written this
entire look Oh
prim
don't see me - oh well that's no no cool
but no
that's a great job
very real
yeah Wow
you know he is Carlos was great at
playing warlords Jason I'm just gonna
say yeah tense you have something I want
he owns lost boyo sir it doesn't have
time to answer any dude Maji 11 that's
my son
what the what's happening what real bad
what oh no oh no oh god damn Deborah
Chao can direct I know she's can't wait
for that it'll be one show yeah you've
got two days
luckily I'll have to wait too long oh
man that was such a bummer rely on
Kathleen Kennedy ruining Star Wars this
is a good show I like that this is a
really you know how I know it's a great
show cuz I gotta admit I was not looking
forward to really watching this today
not because I don't like the Mandalorian
yeah I obviously love this show but just
talking about Rises Skywalker and then
knowing what's going around all the eggs
yeah and and so I was like okay you know
those reason I'm avoiding comments
because I want to just keep Star Wars
for me right now but some of that you
know negativity rightfully so because
people are a lot of feel whatever they
feel towards the movie was bleeding over
yeah
but then to go back into the show and
completely forget about its so wrapped
up in this and absorbed in it yeah I I
was very very happy to be here and this
is this is wonderful wow what an episode
plenty to talk about here before we go
into that do want to remind people only
10 minutes reaction highlights include
its offal in three action Street along
four Mandalorian all the episodes are
under patreon page we actually do stream
along for many shows and those shows are
our agents of shield stranger things
season three got them a couple other
ones as well and their shows where we
have stream alongs
and reaction highlights as another
option for them just like what you saw
here with the Mandalorian and those
shows are supernatural Hunter hunter
Code Geass Death Note my hero academia
movie included attack on Titan and their
other shows as well and maybe more to
come down the road so guys if you can do
us a solid and go check out our patreon
page today they do a great job at
helping keep our channel alive plus all
the extra bonus content as well anywho
what a great episode yeah love the
tension in the mood behind it and
paranoia I really appreciate how
narrative ly it's all tying up we
addressed it in the last reaction for
with hilberg although was remembered as
that episode bill burr wanted bill burr
episode right that one we talked about
how we know people have been complaining
that the show is very episodic I think
it's kind of a silly complaint I think
we're very much used to serialize
television now especially for things
like cable and streaming I think network
television is you know aiming to do more
of that when it comes to streaming and
we're cable we usually expect serialized
TV we've been on board for the episodic
thing in reminds it's like an old
western shows in a way I think it's cool
like adventure of the week so it's like
tie-ins and this seem to beat them like
to really go back to tying it all in
right from Cara Doon of course with
grief and queal and then IG 11 yeah
that's like they're gonna bring him a
lot of characters back into the fold
here but bringing a more full circle and
then you know even the client Herzog the
poet I swear he wrote his own dialogue
for this I wouldn't be surprised so it's
cool to see how it's all piecing
together with the ultimate resolve will
be it of course was more mystery things
set up but it makes a lot of sense at
least looking right now I don't know how
the season will and the structure thus
far it's like you know this thing goes
down with baby Yoda they go on the run
for a little while realize they can't
run forever and then have to go back and
face the problem you know and that seems
pretty sensible or we've put in us every
episode they all sort of borrow from
some action movie trope that we've seen
before pretending to be a capture
hostage so they can break in and kill
the client was it a little predictable
sure did not see the moment coming
though when Mothe guns down everyone
yeah yeah with death troopers leading
the way that moment surprised me because
I wasn't expecting an outside force to
intervene yeah blow everyone away
I wasn't expecting for freaking Werner
Herzog to be killed off either
but baby Yoda you
and life force abilities that was cool
yeah life force and force choke
I mean hey if you got the force you got
a forced choke at least one time yeah
you gotta use it to cheat at armrest is
the first time you see the force choke
use not out of just pure hate but better
protection yeah not who's done somebody
in some kind of intergalactic boardroom
Anakin slightly forced choke Padme in
Episode three because he thought he was
being betrayed but this was like a car
bro if I'm a good side this is me baby
Yoda is in touch with the dark side if
he's using the Force to choke people you
agree Jedi no what is he
now I knew you were just looking now for
daddy mando Moff Gideon there's some
vibes here that I'm getting that could
potentially be the roots of the first
order I don't know if the show is aiming
to fill in this gap I don't care for
them to do that oh I don't care for that
to be the jeevan's knees no I suppress
it with the power of mind control when
you suppress the dark side I don't want
this show to try to do something where
there try to fill in gaps for between
Return of the Jedi and the force awakens
it didn't make it clear I just got the
impression because it seems like he's
making some progress with the Empire
rising back up again it's some some
fashion when you have that whole
monologue from a Hertzog about how like
the Empire makes everything it touches
so much better wide reach and their
resources and they bring peace to
everybody and a man early with his
visual representation they look outside
it's like of course out here it's crap
yes we're all the X Empire losers some
shitty planet no harem there's the other
planets where they look great okay and a
lot of people are happier I'm excited
for Giancarlo Esposito man he just has a
way of carrying himself oh yeah and it's
cool to use this moment to tease him for
the next episode you know you guys
really formidable almost impossible
looking situation and an actor we've
been waiting to see during the show like
it's pretty good cliffhanger
especially leading into the last episode
like he's good so good at being calm and
terrifying yeah absolutely I know that
broke my heart the way they capture
edited it together yeah maybe there was
a take where he got shot or something in
baby Yoda Falls make sense here you're
the next ones the last episode I think
yeah this season you got a have no it'll
be renewed hopefully do it well the main
reason people watch is the way it was
edited was it was really good because it
left for a shocking last image yeah lets
you wonder for a minute like is he using
him as bait yeah be negligent today is
he dead they make some doll what was it
what was it it's actually more powerful
just show him laying there in that we
that they lost the situation because
it's so much colder and more sad and in
its own way they just leave him out
there there's and you know you don't
really cut away from mandos perspective
all that often that moment is not mandos
perspective when you see quill laying
there but in a way that's the closest
you can get to putting you in Manas
perspective of like where are you I'm
trying to reach you hello hello who were
pinned down then you see why I'm
responding back to him uh-huh
so heartbreaking mm-hm and I mean I
appreciate that they like I really
enjoyed that character and it's things
like this to give a show weight
something that the movies have had the
recent movies at least about a tougher
time doing is making the stakes feel
real by having not true everybody's at
the top of their form well the thing
would Quayle it was so sad as you you
learn his backstory sort of forced into
the empire servitude and then and bought
his freedom through hard work yeah and
then ultimately is gone down and killed
by the Empire which is just I wonder
what its gonna do for Amanda's character
I mean he's developing feelings you know
yeah and he's just lost somebody who was
willing to risk it's like I believe yeah
he would take that pretty seriously Gina
Carano is acting and this one was
significantly better like I had
she was bad in the fourth episode I just
thought like she was like yeah she had
to do here she actually made a strong
impression in her performance to me Carl
Weathers yeah yeah I love the art he's
going yeah oh man I'd like that whole
he's got his pose well you know that's
the official greeting power or you know
like an opening ceremonious gesture and
I like the mystery they built it very
aware that they're letting us flail over
here going who is he trustworthy or not
it's a movie moment for sure but I like
the whole bit with baby Yoda and the
healing and then you know the the plan
gets revealed and all that you know
something tells me I G 11 is gonna show
up at this fight it helps save the day
yeah I feel like that line about he can
defend placed strategically well I kept
thinking that they're gonna he's gonna
save the day when quill was riding the
the blur trying to get baby Oda back to
the ship this subverted an expectation
like a lot of the episodes have been
kind of predictable in the way they the
outcomes often resolve and then this one
was different with a with a really great
cliffhanger so I just think a GOI was
gonna show up and redeem whatever
element was and say baby Oda
yeah or something be instrumental in the
operations somehow yeah I just love when
it when a show can leave you with that
real dismay when it ends like a
cliffhanger like that where it's that
natural reaction I want to continue yeah
yeah like and that's just a mark of yeah
like effective storytelling an effective
world exploration you know this moot
that Debra Chau creates I think is so
wonderful I can't wait to see you the
show she has all right well the
mandalorian f8 did you guys like this
episode what do you think's going to
happen and the next one that I say 8 you
said night 7 episode chapter 7 the force
awaken force awakens what stood out to
you the most here with any predictions
comment below subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified whenever we got a YouTube
video up hey check us out on patreon we
got all them goodies and I like to end
this with a page of the day shout out to
a lovely human being named L BLB I'm
shouting her
out because she did not have Disney Plus
you know saw some of the reaction
highlights and said screw it I'm gonna
cave and get Disney Plus because she's
not watching our videos and she wanted
to do the stream along with us yeah so
lb thank you because we are Disney
shills that's right and we have sold the
Disney Plus product to you and for every
subscription we get a one thousand
dollar check in the mail everyone who
signs up for $6.99 including yours
$1,000 bill a annual pass to Disneyland
free tickets to every movie so thank you
al for enriching our lives well you have
proven our value in the marketplace yes
but only the Disney marketplace everyone
else we're not on anybody else l sirs -
thank you so much
I hope you have a Merry Christmas and
you you are one of the greatest gifts we
can it's not like you're an item just
you know your your existence is a gift
in and of itself yeah you are not an
object despite what everyone